HANNITY, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
>> Sean: IT'S A HANNITY
INVASION.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BUSY NEWS NIGHT.
WE'RE TRACKING MULTIPLE BREAKING
MAJOR NEWS STORIES AS WE BEGIN.
TONIGHT, THE DEEP STATE IS IN
EVEN MORE DEEP TROUBLE.
NO PUN INTENDED.
U.S. ATTORNEY GEN DURHAM HAS
BEEN APPOINTED TO INVESTIGATE
THE ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIA PROBE.
THIS IS HUGE NEWS.
THIS IS THE BOOMERANG WE'VE BEEN
TELLING YOU ABOUT.
A MASSIVE STEP FORWARD.
DURHAM IS A NONPARTISAN CAREER
U.S. ATTORNEY.
HE SPECIALIZES IN UNCOVERING
CORRUPTION AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
BACK IN THE 2000s, DURHAM WAS
APPOINTED TO INVESTIGATE THE
FBI'S BOSTON POLICE FIELD OFFICE
AND RESULTING IN A CONVICTION OF
AN FBI SPECIAL AGENT AS ANOTHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL
CONNECTED TO WHITEY BULGER.
IN 2009, HE WAS INVESTIGATING
ABUSES IN THE CIA.
DURHAM HAS SUCCESSFULLY
PROSECUTED DOZENS OF GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS, GANG MEMBERS, DRUG
TRAFFICKERS, ALIKE.
HE HAS BEEN PRAISED BY MEMBERS
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE FOR
HIS STEADY AND CAUTION PURSUIT
OF TRUTH AND JUSTICE.
TONIGHT HE'S FOCUSED ON WHY OUR
COUNTRIES MOST SENSITIVE
INTELLIGENCE TOOLS WERE TURNED
AGAINST ITS OWN CITIZENS AT THE
HEIGHT OF A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
FOX NEWS IS REPORTING THAT
DURHAM IS COLLABORATING WITH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, MICHAEL
HOROWITZ, IN HIS ONGOING
INVESTIGATION AND FISA ABUSE AND
FISA ABUSE FRAUD.
GET THIS, DURHAM'S INVESTIGATION
IS NOT NEW.
IT IS NOW BEEN UNDERWAY FOR
WEEKS AND POSSIBLY EVEN MONTHS.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, THE BAD ACTORS
IN THE DEEP STATE, THEY'RE
GETTING VERY NERVOUS TONIGHT.
THEY'RE NOW TURNING ON EACH
OTHER.
LITTLE CIRCULAR FIRING SQUAD
FORMING.
LISA PAGE, PETER STRZOK ARE
BLAMING LORETTA LYNCH FOR THE
RIGGING OF THE INVESTIGATION
INTO HILLARY CLINTON AND HER
SERVER AND OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
BRUCE OHR IS BLAMING THE DOJ AND
FBI OFFICIALS FOR IGNORING HIS
WARNING ABOUT CHRISTOPHER STEELE
AND THE DOSSIER.
THAT WAS IN AUGUST OF 2016.
JAMES COMEY IS TRASHING STRZOK
AND PAGE ON NATIONAL TV AND HE
AND ROD ROSENSTEIN ARE ATTACKING
EACH OTHER'S CHARACTER.
ANDREW McCABE IS ATTACKING
ANYBODY WITH A PULSE.
IT'S CRISIS MODE FOR THE DEEP
STATE.
IT'S EVERY MAN AND WOMAN FOR
THEMSELVES.
EVEN COMEY'S FORMER GENERAL
COUNSEL AT THE FBI, JAMES BAKER,
HE'S TRYING TO GET AHEAD OF THIS
STORY BY WARNING THAT HOROWITZ
IS GOING TO UNCOVER SOME MAJOR
MISTAKES IN THE FISA PROCESS.
YOU THINK?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS
LOOKING AT EVERYTHING THAT WE
DID.
IF THE I.G. FINDS MISTAKES AND I
EXPECT IT TO HAPPEN THIS TIME.
AT LEAST FROM THE INTENT OF THE
PEOPLE THAT I DEALT WITH, THERE
WAS NO INTENTION TO DO ANYTHING
WRONG OR ILLEGAL.
>> Sean: MISTAKES?
LIKE USING UNTRUE, SOMETHING
THAT IS UNVERIFIABLE, RUSSIAN
MISINFORMATION, PROPAGANDA,
OUTRIGHT LIES?
PAID FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON TO
LITERALLY INFORM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BECAUSE IT WAS LEAKED TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," DAVID
CORN AS THE VERY BASIS FOR A
WARRANT TO SPY NOT ONLY ON AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN, BUT AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN WORKING FOR THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THE ENTIRE
OPPOSITION PARTY THAT NONE OF
THESE GUYS WE KNOW WANTED TO WIN
THAT ELECTION.
INTERESTING.
LIKE WHEN JAMES COMEY SWORE THAT
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO THE FISA
COURT, HE SIGNED THE FIRST FISA
APPLICATION.
HE SIGNED THAT THAT WAS TRUE AND
CORRECT AND VERIFIED.
CORROBORATED.
THE APPLICATION HAS THE WORD
"VERIFIED" ON IT.
MR. BAKER, THAT'S NOT A MISTAKE.
THAT'S WILLFUL, PREMEDITATED, A
CRIMINAL ACT MADE FOR THE SOLE
PURPOSE OF FRAUD WHILE TRYING TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY RIG A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IN THE
UNITED STATES.
NOT ONLY DID COMEY MAKE NO
ATTEMPT TO VERIFY STEELE'S
INTELLIGENCE, THERE'S AGAIN MORE
GROWING EFFORT TONIGHT THAT
COMEY NEW FULL WELL THAT STEELE
WAS COMPLETELY UNRELIABLE.
A BRAND NEW REPORT BREAKING FROM
A REPORTER FROM THE HILL, JOHN
SOLOMON SHOWING THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL DID IN FACT
INFORM A HIGH-RANKING OFFICIAL
AT THE FBI ABOUT HER MEETING
WITH STEELE.
MANY DAYS, TEN DAYS, BEFORE THE
FISA WARRANT AGAINST CARTER
PAGE, THE FIRST ONE, WAS
SUBMITTED IN OCTOBER OF 2016.
HERE ON THIS DEVELOPING STORY,
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER, JOHN
SOLOMON WITH US, THIS IS GETTING
IMPORTANT INTERESTING BY THE
DAY.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THEY WERE
WARN, ESPECIALLY BRUCE OHR.
THAT WAS IN HIS CLOSED-DOOR
TESTIMONY.
IN THIS CASE, THIS WOMAN, SHE
WARNED THEM DIRECTLY.
>> YEAH, IT'S IMPORTANT.
FOR THE FIRST TIME WE KNOW WHO
IN THE CHAIN OF COMMAND GOT
TIPPED OFF BY THE STATE
DEPARTMENT THAT STEELE HAD MADE
THIS REMARKABLE APPEARANCE ON
OCTOBER 2016.
THE TERN, STEPHEN LAYCOCK WAS IN
THE FBI COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
THE DIVISION DOING THE RUSSIA
MY SOURCES TELL ME THAT HE
FORWARDED THE INFORMATION TO THE
TEAM RUNNING THE RUSSIA CASE,
WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN PETE
STRZOK'S TEAM.
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT?
WE KNOW FROM THE OCTOBER 11th
MEETING NOTES THE STATE
DEPARTMENT DETECTED FROM STEELE
INACCURATE INFORMATION ABOUT HIS
ALLEGATIONS ABOUT RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THAT HE HAD AN ELECTION DEADLINE
A POLITICAL MOTIVE, TO GET THIS
DIRT ON TRUMP OUT TO THE PUBLIC,
AND THAT HE HAD BEEN LEAKING TO
THE MEDIA SPECIFICALLY "THE
WASHINGTON POST" AND "NEW YORK
TIMES" THE FBI SHOULD HAVE GONE
AND CHECKED THAT OUT.
THAT'S WHAT FORMER PEOPLE THAT
HELD MR. LAYCOCK'S JOB TODAY.
PRIOR PREDECESSORS SAY THAT'S
WHAT WE DO.
WHEN WE GET A TIP OFF, YOU GO
BACK AND CHECK IT.
YOU DON'T PROCEED WITH YOUR FISA
AND IGNORE WHAT WE ON.
A NEW WITNESS IDENTIFY FOR THOSE
IN CONGRESS AND THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S INVESTIGATIONS.
>> Sean: WHAT DOWN ABOUT WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL REPORT AND MR. DURHAM
WHO HAS BEEN REPORTED?
AND OUR REPORTING SHOWS THAT
HE'S BEEN WORKING A NUMBER OF
WEEKS, MAYBE MONTHS.
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY THIS GIVES THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL INVESTIGATION
THE ABILITY TO GET GRAND JURY
SUBPOENAS TO A SITTING U.S.
ATTORNEY.
CREATES A NEW TOOL THAT
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S DON'T HAVE.
THEY'RE USUALLY ADMINISTRATIVE
IN THEIR APPROACH.
KEY WITNESSES NO LONGER FALL
UNDER THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
PURCHASE VUE.
FORMER EMPLOYEES BECAUSE THEY
WERE FIRED OR RESIGNED.
THE U.S. ATTORNEY HAS A GREAT
REPUTATION OF INVESTIGATING
FAIRLY AND HONESTLY AND TOUGHLY.
PRIOR CONTROVERSIES INSIDE THE
FBI.
HE'S INVOLVED IN THAT TOOL OF
THE GRAND JURY SUBPOENA.
IT'S ANOTHER PIECE THAT CAN BE
PLAYED HERE TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM.
>> Sean: JOHN SOLOMON, THANKS
FOR JOINING US.
TRUTH AND JUSTICE, AS WE'VE BEEN
TELLING YOU, IT'S HAPPENING.
CASCADING DOWN.
NOBODY IN THE DEEP STATE IS SAFE
FOR JUSTICE.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE TURNING ON
EACH OTHER.
OPENER BOOMERANG IS IN FULL
EFFECT.
THE RUSSIAN HOAX IS IN THE REAR
VIEW MIRROR.
MUELLER IS OVER.
ANYTHING YOU HEAR GOING FORWARD
IS NOISE.
THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T COLLUDE OR
OBSTRUCT.
AND THE FAKE PHONY NARRATIVE AND
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IS DEAD AND
BURIED AND NOT COMING BACK.
THE ANTI-TRUMP MOB AND THE MEDIA
CAN'T LET IT GO, THAT INCLUDES,
BY THE WAY, JAMES CLAPPER THAT
WAS LITERALLY BEGGING CNN TO GET
BACK ON MESSAGE, GET BACK TO THE
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT'S BEEN
DISPROVEN FOUR TIMES.
GREAT TV COVERAGE.
>> WE'RE KIND OF LOSING SIGHT
WHAT WAS THE CAUSE OF ALL OF
THIS, THE PREDICATE FOR THIS,
THE RUSSIANS.
THE RUSSIAN ENGAGEMENT.
NOW WE KNOW APPARENTLY DOZENS OF
CASES, RUSSIAN OPEN TIES AND
INTELLIGENCE CONNECTIONS WERE
TRYING TO ENGAGE WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S WHAT THE CONCERN WAS AND
THE PREDICATE FOR ANY OF
THESE -- THIS INVESTIGATION.
I WISH PEOPLE PAID MORE
ATTENTION TO VOLUME ONE.
THEY EXHAUSTED DETAILS ABOUT
WHAT THE RUSSIANS DID.
WE'RE LOSING SIGHT OF THAT.
>> Sean: JAMES, MANY REPUBLICANS
LIKE CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES
HAVE BEEN WARNING ABOUT THE
RUSSIAN THREAT FOR YEARS.
2014, MOST RECENTLY.
THIS ALL HAPPENED UNDER YOUR
WATCH AND BIDENS AND OBAMA'S
WATCH.
IT WAS THEN PRESIDENT OBAMA, HE
WAS LAUGHING IT OFF.
TELL VLADIMIR I HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY AFTER THE ELECTION.
LOOK AT VOLUME ONE OF THE
MUELLER REPORT, IT WAS THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN THAT REBUFFED RUSSIAN
OPERATIONS EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY.
WHILE IT WAS THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN THAT PAID FOR RUSSIA
DISINFORMATION IN THE FORM OF A
DIRTY DOSSIER FULL OF RUSSIAN
LIES.
"NEW YORK TIMES" SUGGESTING THAT
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION FROM THE
GET-GO.
THE DIRTY DOSSIER THAT YOU,
JAMES CLAPPER, LEAKED TO YOUR
CURRENT EMPLOYER, FAKE CNN,
YEAH, THAT ONE.
LEAKING IS NOT A CONCERN OF ADAM
THE COWARDLY SCHIFF WHO DOESN'T
SEEM TO CARE ABOUT GOVERNMENT
LEAKING OR ABUSE OF POWER.
SCHIFF IS ON AN ALL-CONSUMING
MISSION TO SLEER
MISSION TO SMEER
MISSION TO SMEAR AND ATTACK THE
FBI WHO IS TRYING TO GET ROBERT
MUELLER TO APPEAR BEFORE
CONGRESS.
MAYBE HE DOESN'T REALIZE IT'S
OVER YET.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE'RE IN CONVERSATION WITH
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
IT'S NOT THAT THEY CONFIRMED THE
DATE.
THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT HAS TO.
I THINK THE REPUBLICANS AND I
THINK THE ATTORNEY GENERAL EVEN
UNDERSTAND THAT.
THAT'S WHY BARR HAS SAID HE'S
NOT GOING TO STAND IN THE WAY OF
THE MUELLER TESTIMONY.
HE CAN'T.
>> Sean: HE SAID HE HAD EVIDENCE
AND EVERYTHING.
THE ONLY ONE ON TAPE COLLUDING
WITH RUSSIANS IS HIM.
HE WAS TALKING TO A RUSSIAN
HOKESTER THAT SAID HE HAD
DAMMING INFORMATION ON DONALD
TRUMP.
HE SAID, WHAT IS THE NATURE OF
THE INFORMATION?
NOTHING.
OF COURSE, OF COURSE.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
FOUR SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS
CLEARED PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE FBI'S NINE-MONTH
INVESTIGATION UNDER COMEY CAME
UP WITH NOTHING.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S 20-MONTH
INVESTIGATION, NOTHING.
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE'S
THE BIPARTISAN SENATE
INVESTIGATION, NOTHING.
THEN YOU HAVE SLEEPY CREEPY
UNCLE JOE BIDEN WHO IS DESPERATE
TO WIN AND DYLANATE HIS OWN
PART, HE'S NOT GOING TO LET
FACTS GET IN A WAY IN A QUESTION
AND ANSWER SESSION ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, SLEEPY CREEPY
UNCLE JOE PUT ON HIS CONSPIRACY
THEORY GAME AND PUSHED HIS
FAVORITE THEORY.
SHOCKING.
LIE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
HOPE IT WORKS.
>> HE'S AN ILLEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT IN MY MIND.
THAT'S IT.
HE'S ILLEGITIMATE.
MY BIGGEST FEAR IS HE WILL DO
WITH IT THE HELP OF VLAD, HIS
BEST PAL AND WE'LL BE STUCK FOR
SIX MORE YEARS OF THIS GUY THAT
IS TERRIFYING.
IT'S TERRIFYING.
>> WOULD YOU BE MY VICE
PRESIDENT?
FOLKS, LOOK, I ABSOLUTELY AGREE.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE TO DO
HERE, WE HAVE TO GET THIS
STRAIGHT IN MY VIEW.
>> LIKE MOST DEMOCRATS RUNNING
FOR OFFICE, BIDEN IS WILLING TO
SAY ANYTHING TO SCORE A CHEAP
POLITICAL POINT.
WHETHER SMEARING A NOMINEE TO
THE U.S. SUPREME COURT OR
ATTACKING A 16-YEAR-OLD HIGH
SCHOOL KID, DARING TO WEAR A
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN HAT OR
PUSHING A RUSSIA HOAX OVER
NEARLY THREE YEARS NOW.
THE LEFT'S QUEST FOR POWER KNOWS
NO BOUNDS.
BIDEN AND BOMB GAVE US A SHOT.
THEY GAVE US EIGHT MILLION ON
POVERTY, 13 MILLION ON FOOD
STAMPS.
THE LOWEST HOME HOMEOWNERSHIP
RATE IN 51 YEARS.
NOT ONE YEAR TO GIVE US 3% GDP
GROWTH AND TOOK ON MORE DEALT
THAN ALL THREE 43 PRESIDENTS
BEFORE THEM.
JOE, RUN ON THAT.
SLEEPY CREEPY HAPPENED ON YOUR
WATCH.
WHAT DID YOU KNOW AND WHEN DID
YOU KNOW IT?
WE WILL ALWAYS DEMAND THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE EQUAL